you have said you've settled you're not
a great one for the research you must
have done you must have done some for
this yes you must have done something
for this i lovely polly who's a movement
coach and I just it turns out can't
change what my body does so I still walk
like me which is I've been told quite
like a farmer and it's you and Prince
Phillip walking up the guard it filmed
on the back of my head no it's the two
of you walking up towards you out the
god yeah but you go to extraordinary
lengths to reach you're going to
ridiculous things I don't think it
necessarily is necessary but I enjoy it
I do love it I love it you will you
brilliant at school at research and
projects yeah I was a foot [ __ ] at it
and then you've got a friend is that a
friend of yours who's a psychic one
story comes out and then obliterates oh
yeah I did meet a psychic who's a friend
of mine and I was seeing her she's got
lots and lots of different strings her
bones she does healing and she does
other things and but she also has a
talent for mediumship and as I was
dissing her for something else she said
Oh Margaret is here does that mean
anything that and I said yes it does and
I suddenly thought well I've got if I
stay for you yet I've been asked yeah I
hadn't actually said yes at that point
and I said well yeah no actually if
you've got the horse you know the
horse's mouth it's in the room you're
not gonna say yes no actually you know
so and so I said you
and I asked I said would you mind if I
played you and the bio you know she said
well no she did say I think you're a
better idea than the other actor oh the
other idea the other you know the other
who was the other they never told me how
about the other possibility gunshot
right now but there are it was a very
typically a typical Margaret thing in
the shoe had miss her I have met her she
had a way she had a way of sometimes
complimenting you and putting you down
at the same time she was it and the fact
that she said oh yeah I think you're
better than me it was just like you
never knew where you were with her then
she came through with another note which
was useful whether it came whether it
was true because the psychic was
fantastically intuitive all there really
was the ghosts tomorrow it to me I don't
I don't know but the note was good in it
says they get the smoking right okay and
I smoked in a particular way and always
remember that the cigarette holder is as
much a weapon for expression as anything
else and that was a good note and she
was somebody who was innately dramatic
if your royal you can't necessarily talk
much you're a walking icon they were
walking so she was very she was very I
think conscious about the silhouette and
whatever she did with her body and
particularly their hands and so you know
anyway and my waxing know I love you I
just don't just I you don't believe in -
well they're people other people do
believe and vice versa
[Music]